[Crowd chanting:] Kobe!
Kobe! Kobe!
- The passing,
the way guys reacted to it—
- I'm still in shock.
- When that happened that day,
it seemed like
the world stopped.
- To have it happen
so tragically,
it was one of those moments
that I think shook the world.
- It's terribly sad,
what happened,
but, you know,
his memory's gonna live on,
not just through basketball,
but, you know,
through the people
he brought into this game.
- Welcome to the Kobe Show.
- [Announcer:]
Bryant to the basket.
Inside. Oh, what a finish.
- [Announcer:] Kobe. Oh!
- [Announcer:]
What a reverse by Kobe Bryant.
- The fiercest
of all competitors.
- He was a superhero
on the basketball court.
- [Announcer:] One of the best
players to ever lace it up.
- Back-to-back-to-back.
- [Announcer:]
Five NBA titles, an MVP.
- He brought his own style,
his own mindset to the game.
- He never took a night off.
He competed every possession.
- Made people who hated him
spend a lot of money
to come watch him.
So that's when you know
you're great.
[Buzzer sounding]
- [Announcer:]
He is hard to believe.
- The biggest
thing that everybody, you know,
admired about Kobe
was the competitiveness.
- An all-time winner
that represented the toughness,
the "play through everything"
type of mindset.
- Take big shots,
make big shots.
- He was one
of the hardest-working guys
that you ever wanted
to meet.
- I've never seen anybody
work like that.
- I felt like
he was just invincible.
- That's Kobe Bryant.
- [Announcer:] There we go.
Here comes Kobe. Slam dunk.
- [Announcer:]
Kobe with a sick move in the lane.
- [Announcer:] Wow.
Did you see the move by the kid?
That's Kobe.
- Whoo!
- [Announcer:]
He's putting on a show.
- [Announcer:] 360 turn.
Slam.
- [Announcer:]
Giant slam dunk.
What a move by Kobe.
- 8 Kobe was the
swaggy Kobe.
- Young, athletic,
kind of fun.
- Wear a chain, dunk on you,
throw lobs to Shaq.
- [Announcer:] Bryant to Shaq.
- Favorite Kobe moment—
- We were playing
the Denver Nuggets.
I would yell out,
"Watch the press,"
and he would look at me,
and the smile would
come over his face
cuz he knew I saw something.
- He got the full-court pass
and wrapped it behind his back
and did the reverse dunk.
- [Announcer:] Oh!
What'd I just see?
- I was like, "See?
Listen to me.
I'll take you places."
[Chuckling]
- Favorite moment
from Kobe's career—
I remember watching
the right-elbow pull-up
against the Phoenix Suns.
- [Announcer:]
Bryant for the win. Bang!
- Kobe No. 8 would shoot
27 times this quarter,
"If I gotta win this game."
- [Announcer:] Kobe Bryant
pulls up with a shot
and hits the basket
with 2.6 to go.
- Obviously remember
the 81-point game.
- He had 81 points
in the game.
- [Announcer:] He pump-fakes for two.
Kobe's got the Laker record!
- Players talk about
being in the zone.
He was in the super zone.
He could not miss.
- [Announcer:]
Ladies and gentlemen,
you have witnessed
the second-greatest
scoring performance
in NBA history.
- I just remember thinking
that it wasn't even real.
It was amazing to watch.
- [Announcer:]
Bryant on the pull-up.
Puts it in.
The Lakers repeat,
back-to-back titles.
Bryant, the drive.
Oh-ho!
Kobe Bryant on a rack attack.
Double punch reverse.
Oh! Yes!
- [Announcer:]
Sweet stuff by No. 24.
- No. 24 was
a lot more determined.
- He was locked in,
he was focused.
- That real alpha
who’s not taking any prisoners.
- My favorite Kobe moment—
Matt Barnes
was taking the ball to bounce,
and he faked a pass-and-bounce
at Kobe's face,
and he didn't flinch,
blink or anything.
- That's when he turned into
a basketball genius
and became unstoppable.
- [Announcer:] Back to Bryant.
Is he gonna try another one?
He is. Yes!
He's on fire, the "Mamba."
- Mamba mentality is
a real laser-sharp focus,
showing up every day,
willing to work.
- [Announcer:] Kobe slithers.
Mamba.
- It's a level
of relentlessness,
passion, work ethic
that's just unmatched.
- That's what mambas do.
They don't back down.
- At the end of the day,
what it allowed him to do
was will himself
and will his team
to victories,
to championships.
It was almost
superhuman.
- [Announcer:] That is just
greatness personified.
- A lotta people love Kobe.
- Kobe was a leader of our game,
- [Announcer:]
Inspired a whole generation
of basketball players.
- He was someone
that everyone looks up to,
especially this generation
of players.
- So in the words
of Kobe Bryant, "Mamba out,"
but in the words of us,
“Not forgotten.” Live on, brother.
- Kobe's impact on the league
is extraordinary.
- He's definitely one of the most
inspirational basketball players
I ever grew up watching.
- He made it OK to be
obsessed with basketball
and to just put everything
you had into the game.
- For him
to just have the mindset
of wanting to help others
and the younger generation
was really special.
- He's a role model
for so many kids.
He's like their Superman.
- He was our
generation's Michael Jordan.
- We are now
the people carrying the torch,
and we're influenced
very heavily by his play
and his mentality.
- The game will forever
be indebted to him.
[Crowd chanting:] Kobe!
Kobe! Kobe! Kobe! Kobe!
♪♪♪